[موسيقى]
قبل سنوات طوال التقيت بحازم صغير لغايه
حوار في روافد
ثم بين فتره واخرى كنا نلتقي ليس لهدف او
لغايه طرح السؤال ما والاستماع الى رايه
الممتع في هذه المساله او تلك كنا نلتقي
لصدفه تقاطع الدروب ولكن كانت تبدو عليه
ملامح اثقال الخيبه المتزايده يوما بعد
اخر
يبدو هناك عطب كبير يصعب اصلاحه احدث
صدوعا عميقه وشاسعه في بنيه بلدان اتخذتها
رهينه زمر من اهلها سمت نفسها نظاما
يمكن القول ان حازم صغير هو من بين اكثر
المفكرين والكتاب السياسيين العرب الذين
امتحنوا وقراوا وتاملوا وكتبوا في احوال
هذه الانظمه هو احزابها في المشرق العربي
وتحديدا في تلك الانظمه التي يمكن
تسميتها
بنسخ مشوهه عن الديكتاتوريات الغربيه
بشقيها النازي واستليني
لقد عين نشوءها منذ سقوط الامبراطوريه
العثمانيه وحتى
يومنا هذا حيث على ما يبدو ان النفق صار
مديدا وطويلا والعتمه اكثر حلكه
كان هناك فرص كما قال كان هناك فرص لم
تستغل كما ينبغي هي ايضا خطفت من الزمر
التي اقتنصتها لتابيد حضورها في رفع
شعارات توهم بنشوء دوله ما لكنها في
جوهرها كانت تؤسس لكل ما يديم سطاتها
وظلمها وعنفها ويؤجل قيام الدوله
شو تغير شو تغير فيك من
الالفين خلينا نقول من حوالي 13 سنه او 15
حتى الان شو اللي تغير يعني اللي تغير
الحقيقه بعد التجربه الاخيره تبع
تجربه الثورات
هو
مزيد من الاحباط ومزيد من الشعور بانه ما
راح اقول ما في شيء بيتغير بس انه شروط
التغير
كثير كبيره
وكتير صعبه يعني غير متوفره يعني ما انا
متوفره ومنهم من السهل تتوفر
يعني مناعه بسيطه انه عشر ثورات
في العالم العربي اذا اخذنا بعين الاعتبار
الفصل الاخير يعني لبنان العراق الجزائر
السودان عشر ثورات كلها فشلت
لما بتفشل 10 ثورات تباعا
بغض النظر عن النوم ونقول هذا السبب بس
المشترك هو
يعني هذه اللي بيقولوا الصدف اللي بتصير
قانون اذا تتكررت هالقد
المعنى في عطل عميق جدا جدا جدا
بوقعنا العربي يعني
باوضاعنا بامكانيه تغييرها بالسعي لشيء
افضل
فكيف انه الهزائم كلها واحد
الوقيع عم يعيشها فكريا وسياسيا بس بلبنان
تحديدا انا كلبناني عم عيشه شخصيا كمان
يعني موجود فيها صحيح
فبتحس خاصه انت يعني يعني رفقت هذه
التجربه
تجربه التامل والتفكير هذه المنطقه خاصه
بالانظمه
الانظمه العربيه اللي
احتل العسكر رفقت وتاملت فيها وكتبت فيها
الكثير الى ان توصلت مرورا بالثورات طبعا
وحتى الان يعني في هذا التاريخ نحن هلا
بالالفين 2023
باواخر فبراير
يبدو انت
وتكرر اظن هذا الكلام انه
لم تجد املا يعني محبط
لديك احساس بالخيبه
ولكن دائما الامل مقفل بظنك
ما بعرف يعني القصه اذا كان فعلا يعني مثل
بعض بصيغوها تفاؤل وتفاؤل وامل وياس بس
اذا وضعنا جانبا
الاوصاف يعني
الواقع القائم العمل نعيشه واقع مسدود
واقع مسدود فعلي يعني مثلا تخيل
نظام النظام بشار الاسد بعده حي يرزق شيء
مثل العراق
بلد غني بكل معاني الكلمه
ما عم يقدر يقلع ما عم يقدروا يقف على
رجليه يعني مطروح وجوده على المحك فلازمه
اللبنان كان ذاتها مره
التجربه العربيه المطله على العالم المحل
اللي في درجه بعيده جدا من الحريات
السياسيه والنقابيه والاعلاميه والى اخره
وصل الحاله الزهريه اللي نعرفها هلا
يعني كتير بشع انك تلاقي
بمعزل
المتشائمين او متفائلين
انك تلاقي وضع يعني هيدي بتضربه مثل
البلدان اللي
ماضيها احسن من حاضرها وحاضرها حيكون احسن
من مستقبلها لانه كمان في احيان كتيره
مجتمعاته
بس بيكون مبين في بصيص نور في امل في شيء
ممكن تبني عليه لمرحله لاحقه هون ما مبينش
اذا اردنا ان نعدد الاسباب التي ابدت
تقريبا الماساه فهي كثيره
وقد اشار اليها حازم صغير في كتاباته التي
قرا فيها طبيعه هذه الانظمه وطبيعه
احزابها كحزب البعث مثلا بشقيه او بنسختيه
العراقيه والسوريه وفي كتابه الاخر
المشرق العربي وفي مئات الابحاث والمقالات
ويقول ان هذه الانظمه لديها القدره ليس
على تدمير حاضر هذه الشعوب وتحطيم ثوراتها
وامالها فقط بل لديها القدره على تدمير
الماضي والحاضر والمستقبل دفعه واحده وفي
الواقع هذا ما تعيشه وعاشته هذه المجتمعات
التي كانت سيئه الحظ انها علمت في شكل
دوله هي في الواقع التاليف ناجح لزمره
وجدت فرصتها في التاريخ وتسعى لت ابيد هذه
الفرصه حتى على ركام البلاد لذلك من يتامل
في الحواضر التاريخيه وفي المدينه العربيه
بشكل عام يجد بعضها ركاما بحجرها وبشرها
نتيجه دورات العنف والقتل وما بقي منها
يتاكل الاجتماعيا وعمرانيا وينهار من
النسيان والفقر او الافقار الذي سبته هذه
الانظمه
طيب هذه القوه اللي استمدتها هذه الانظمه
يعني هذا يعني انها شديده القوه من اين من
اين اتت هذه القوه قوتها قوتها يعني غالبا
اجت من عناصر كثيره
اول عنصر من العناصر
وتحالفت مع تفتت مجتمعات وزادت بها
التفتتن يعني نحن لما اخذنا
كان في عنا انقسامات
طائفيه دينيه دينيه الى اخره كان في فرصه
لتقريب هالفجوات او رقبها الصدوع بحدود
معينه لو نشات انظمه اكثر عدل اكثر حريه
اللي حصل ولا سيما انه على الانظمه تماهت
مع جماعات طائفيه او اثنيه ببلدانها
وقمعت الحياه السيسي والتعبيريه
هالشيء ادى لتفاقم التفاوت بدل ما
نعم راب الصدور الصدوع الكبيره هي الحليف
الاساسي الذي بحول اي ثوره او اي انتفاضه
بعد فتره لحرب اهليه لحرب اهليه حيث جزء
من المجتمع اللي هو يختلف او طائفيا او
دينيا عن هويه الحاكم جزء من المجتمع بسور
جزء من المجتمع بيوقف مع النظام لانه بخاف
من
الاساسي برايي هو انه
هالتخلي عن مواجهه المشكلات الفعليه الى
المجتمعات
اللي هي اساسا بناء وحدات وطنيه او
التخفيف من الفجوات الاجتماعيه الكبرى
بدل
الانهماك والانكباب مش بس الانظمه حتى
المسقفين بدل الانكباب على مواجهه المشكله
صار في هروب ايديولوجي صار في هروب
بشعارات او انه غير قابل للتحقيق او انها
ماسويه من نوع انه صار اي بلد من البلدان
بده يعمل وحده عربيه وبده يبني الاشتراكيه
وبده يحرر فلسطين فيديوهات الامبراليه الى
اخره
فصنعت انصنعت ثقافي
من جهه هي هروب من مواجهه مشاكل الفعليه
لمجتمعاتين هي طريق قصير لمعيسي معيسي قد
تكون معارك حربيه
ماسي قد تكون مشاريع مثل مشروع الوحده
السوريه
المصريين
وافكار المجتمعات يعني مثلا لما حطينا او
هاي الانظمه العسكريه حطت التنميه التنميه
عبر الدوله وسمتها اشتراكيه حطتها محل
الحريه
ادى لفعلا محطه تحرير فلسطين
لهجره بالكافيهات هائله ما قدرت مجتمعاتنا
تعوضها فيما بعد
ولافقار الافقار المجتمع على كل اصعده على
كل الاصعده صلاه ال67 صارت سبعه وستين كنت
مناسبه لمراجعه الاساسيات اللي
حكمت المرحله 52 الى 67 اوكي صار مراجعات
كبيره بس ولا مره الا هالمراجعات كانت
بمعنى ما
[موسيقى]
امتداد طبيعي
للكوارث القائمه
[موسيقى]
ليست رغبه في التشاؤم او الاحباط او لم
ياتي هذا التشاؤم نتيجه تعسر في فهم سر
الوجود مثلا ولكن كلما تاملنا في احوالنا
او لنقل في بيتنا الذي نسكنه نجد انه
يتاكل وينهار على رؤوسنا حتى صار نصفنا في
العراء ونصفنا الاخر مدمى يتبعه
لذلك القول ان الافق مسدود ليس طرفا لغويا
او محاوله على فهم البعيد الغامض
ولكن كي نطقي على نافذه يمكن فتحها على
الامل يمكن المقارنه مع تجارب اخرى في
التاريخ ربما مثلا منذ ما قبل عصر التنوير
والنهضه مرورا بالثوره الفرنسيه والحروب
المديده التي تلتها وصولا الى القرن
العشرين الذي شهد نصفه الاول اكبر حربين
في التاريخ بين هذه الدول نفسها قبل ان
تستقر على ما هي عليه على اسس ديمقراطيه
تحترم حقوق الفرد والانسان وحريه التعبير
الى اخره
في هذه الحال ممكن ان نجد مبررا تاريخيا
لما نعيشه في مجتمعاتنا من مراوحه في
دوامه ماساويه
يعني فينا فينا نعمل المقاربه انه التاريخ
يمشي بنفس السرعه وبعد بعد هذا القطار ما
وصل لعنا هذا القطار التغيير اذا اذا فينا
نسمي بعرف اذا المقارنه مع اوروبا يعني
مفيده بهالمعنى يعني المقارنه مع اوروبا
الاوروبا كان في وجهه صحيح
القصه اخذت مئه سنين
وصارت حروب وصار كذا بس كان في وجهه ممكن
تلمسها باستمرار في وجهات محور ذات مره
حول التنوير حول النهضه حول الثوره
الصناعيه حول الثوره السياسيه
لاحقا حول العولم الى اخره نحن ما في وجهه
عنا حاليا ما في وجهه ما في شيء فيك ترزه
حاليا وتاريخيا ام الان يعني تقول انا
رايي الفرصه الوحيده اللي اتيحت
هي بعد انهيار السلطه العثمانيه مباشره
بعد انهيار السطل العثمانيه حصه الانتداب
على منطقه المشرق العربي على الاقل
الفرنسي والبريطاني ما حدا بحب انه ينتذب
عليه او انه يستعمر بالتاكيد لكن قياسه
بمكان قبل وما حصل بعد
حصلت شغله فينا نسميها فرصه هالفرصه
ترافات مع
الاستعانه باعيان محليين للحكم هني فيما
بعد تولوا الحكم بعد الاستقلالات ترافات
مع مثل ما كلمه انتداب يعني بتقول مع بناء
شويه احزاب اعلام نقابه صحف
فتنه فيها على ادوات العالم الحديث وهي
الفرصه كان ممكن وكان نظري كمان الا هو
والافكار النهضويه في حياه سقفيه معقوله
وكان فيني اشهد ونقاشات فعلا يعني حاره
يعني مثل موضوع طه حسين الشعب الجاهلي او
علي عبد الرازق هيدول امكن خوض هالمعارك
الفكريه الكبيره دون ما حدا ما حدا قتلوه
صح حسين ولا حدا سجن ولا على يعني اخر امر
مش بس هيك
بعد سنوات رجعوا وزروهم صاروا وزراء يعني
بكثير من العيوب والنواقص والقصور والى
اخره بس
اللي صار مره اخرى انه
هالممانعه للفوت
بفكره الدوله للعالم الجديد
نعم هل ممانعه اللي هي
مسكونه بروحها
بوعي سلطاني بوعي امبراطوري ما انه راحت
السلطنه العثمانيه ربما تستانف بسلطنه
عربيه امبراطوريه عربيه يعني كنت دائما في
هيك هل هالطموح هالطموح هيدا من جهه عبر
عنه الحركه الاخوان المسلمين مبكرا ب 28
بعدين الحركه القوميه مثل البعث
حركه القوميه العرب الى اخره
الانظمه العسكريه والامنيه لتحولوا
الايديولوجيه
تستقطب فيها الناس او تبرر حالها فيها
طبعا طبعا اللي زاد الطين بلي وجعل
الاوضاع يعني اصعب اكثر هو نشات اسرائيل
يعني نكبه فلسطين
اعطت هالكلام سوء نعم علما انه كثير
التجارب اللي بتقول انه موضوع فلسطين
هالقد استعمل كذا ريعه لشيء ما كثير له
على فلسطين ولم يزل طبعا ولم يزل اكثر
على اكثر بكثير على الخط كمان المتاجره
بفلسطين
كلفه اخطر لانه عندها لباس مذهبي وطائفي
طبعا ولانه ولانه فعلا لانه فعلا ايران
يعني بتجارب المنطقه
تجربتين كبار
مشكلتهم مش بس انه النظام السياسي سيء مش
كثر انه هن عم يغيروا الطبيعه اول محاوله
لتغيير الطبيعه كانت دوله اسرائيل دوله
اسرائيل اجت اقابت شيله شعب محله وجابت
شعب محله اخر عاد هذا تغيير اساسي للطبيعه
المحاوله التانيه نظام الايراني نظام
الخميني يلي بده يتجاوز حدود
وبلدان من العراق لسوريا للبنان لفلسطين
ايضا
في تغيير للطبيعه والتاني اخطر من الاول
لسبب بسيط الفرق السكاني والجغرافي
بيجعل التمدديه الشيوعيه الايرانيه اكثر
حضورا وتاثيرا والعامل الاساسي هو الطائفه
والمذهبي ايضا لانه تغيير الطبيعه على
مستوى اسرائيل في عنده معوقات معوقات
دينيه يعني فينا نقول لحازم انه انه نحن
العرب بشكل عام بشكل عام عم بحكي محاصرين
بمثلث من من انظمه عند طموح طموح
امبراطوري يعني امبراطوريات بائده عم ترجع
تحيي نفسها بطرق مختلفه منها الامبراطوريه
التركيه
بلباس كمان مذهبي اخواني بمقدار ما
الامبراطوريه الفارسيه بلباس
مذهبي ايضا
والامبراطوريه النظريه نظريا التوراتيه
اللي هي تحدثت عنها اللي هي قيام ونحن
داخل هذا المثلث فينا نوصف هذا يعني اكيد
مع
بوليسيه
بالعشره 15 سنه الاخيره مع صعود الشعبوات
والتراجع
لاصاب من جهه اصاب
ديمقراطيه من جهه ثانيه اصاب التاثير
الغربي
ومن جهه اصاب الاحتكام الى السياسه
وصار اكثر للقوه كتير هالمشاريع
الامبراطوريه المجهده رفعت راسها وعبرت عن
حالها يعني مثلا
كتير بقلوا معنا انه واحد مثلنا ثانياه
ويحكم اكثر بنغوريون
واحد مثل اردوغان اردوغان من المتصور
في الاسس الديمقراطيه للبلديه باخر امر
على تغييرات الواجهه يعني تبعه غالبا رئيس
جمهوريه بيتغير بس النظام كان نظام 79
موجود من 79 حكم رجال الدين
قائم
فهيئه هي طبعا هلا الامبراطوريه كلها
نوازع حتعود تاثيراتها السلبيه اولا على
صعوبه وثاني على محيطه يعني لانه هي لا
تدوم لانه زمن الامبراطوريه خلص
هيدا هلا اكبر
ملحمه اذا بدك من ملاحم نهايه
الامبراطوريات عم يعملها بوتين باوكرانيا
يعني ميل التوسعي
ليبي بعبر بمكان ما عن العجز عن انك تصير
دوله حديثه وديمقراطيه فئه تهرب من التحدي
بانك
بتلطش بلد حدك بتاخذوا او بتحكي عن مؤامره
كونيه عليك او يعني الى اخره تلاقي مبررات
للتوسع طبعا يعني هذه الانظمه هي
اختصاصها في ايجاد الزرائع والمبررات من
المشاكل الفعليين
هو هروب وهذا الهروب هو تاريخي محصن دائما
بالشعارات وبحكمه القائد المعلم والملهم
ومحصن ايضا بتهديد ضمني فيما لو ان احدا
فكر باستبدال هذا النظام باخر وهذا ما
شاهدنا فصوله تراجديه في تلك البلدان
المشتعله بالحروب والفتن
نتابع مع حازم صغير هذه المراجعه الفكريه
والسياسيه لتجربه كانت بوعظم فصولها
ماساويه بامتياز
[موسيقى]